i know there's only
only one like you
there's a way they could have made two
you're the last i ever think
so many things
i love so new only
[Music]
you make me feel this way
you're
[Music]
can
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everything
[Music]
i know that's only
only one like you
there's no way they could have made you
girl you're my reality
but i've lost
[Music]
[Music]
you and me
you are the first
[Music]
uh
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
i can read his righteous sentence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
with the glory
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can you feel it coming in
hold on
but i don't know who i am
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
how could i again
[Music]
some strangers
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're always on the run now
[Music]
[Music]
you really don't remember all the voices
in your head
[Music]
i think
[Music]
hurry up but you really don't remember
in your head
[Music]
how's it going to go down
[Music]
in the afternoon
[Music]
don't believe it's coming back soon
and you really don't remember
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
think they got the aliens
[Music]
hurry up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can best believe
[Music]
hey
[Music]
i got
[Music]
hey
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
he's
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feel uh body
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
uh
is
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
rising up back on the street
[Music]
back on my
[Music]
too
feet
[Music]
you must fight just to keep
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
the
[Music]
is
[Music]
rising up
[Music]
what's the distance
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i am
i hope
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
today
[Laughter]
god
from the lakes of minnesota
to the heroes of tennessee
across the plains of texas
[Music]
from detroit down to houston
and new
every york heart and it's time we stand
and sing
[Music]
that i'm about to be an american
where it is
[Music]
and defend her still today
no doubt i love this land
[Music]
and i can
still today
ah thank you very much thank you let's
see
it's one-third it is a hell of a crowd
for 1 30 in the afternoon
thank you
great state it's fantastic to be back in
north carolina with thousands of loyal
hard-working american people
19 days from now think of that 19 days
you believe this
we're going to win the state of north
carolina we're going to win four more
years in the white house
this election is a simple choice if
biden wins
china wins you see what's going on
[Music]
and when we win north carolina wins
and america wins it's very simple
for the last 47 years joe biden's
betrayed the workers of north carolina
through one act of
economic treachery after another and now
you see what's happening they got caught
stealing folks
[Applause]
finds a servant of the wealthy donors
and globalists and special interests
who got rich bleeding america dry
taking your jobs from north carolina and
every other place
and moving them out of the country and
we turned it around you got to remember
that
these corrupt forces they don't see
our nation as a protector of its
citizens but as a vehicle for personal
profit
and power at your expense and you see it
happening right now
they hold everyone in contempt and they
always put the american worker last and
that's what's happened until i came
along
in fact it's the primary reason i came
along if you think about it
they keep their jobs while outsourcing
your jobs to other countries
countries that you've never even heard
about they build walls for themselves
while forcing your family to suffer the
consequences
of illegal immigration drugs and crime
and you know it very well over here for
five decades
joe biden shipped away your jobs shut
down your factories
threw open your borders and ravaged our
cities while
sacrificing american blood and treasure
in endless foreign wars and you know
they're all coming back they're almost
back
our great soldiers
our great soldiers countries you've
never even heard about
he's the embodiment of the political
class that enriched itself while
draining the economic
life and soul out of our country
yesterday we learned
from newly released emails and i want to
thank the new york post for showing real
bravery
the joe biden has been blatantly lying
about his involvement
in his son's corrupt business dealings
joe biden is a corrupt politician and he
has been corrupt
for many years and everybody in
washington knew it
and just now a little while ago a new
story shows up that hunter
made a deal with a wealthy chinese
business magnet for 10 million
a year for introductions only
introductions i don't know
will you take 10 million a year to
introduce people you have to introduce
dad
dad say hello and by the way dad give
them everything they want
okay give them everything they want dad
hunter also referred to another more
lasting and lucrative arrangement with
the same chinese businessman
that would be so much more interesting
to me and my family that's what he said
that's a quote
these deals were made at the same time
joe biden was letting china steal your
jobs
and take away your factories if biden is
elected
the united states will be owned by china
but we don't have to worry about it
because i can't believe
i can't believe it's going to happen
he's shot just so we understand
we cannot have a leader that's just
about half shot
can you believe can we believe we're
even fighting against this guy
but you know what they're a powerful
party they're a very corrupt party
they're in bed with the media the fake
news right back there
and totally protected by big tech if i
said what he said
they'd be calling for me out of there in
24 hours what this guy has said
two days ago he said i'm running for the
united states senate that's the third
time you said
i'm running for the now that's not look
let's that's not like a regular like
mistake you can make a mistake
he said that and he said other things
but we won't even get into it this
is crazy this is the craziest race
you know what i'm running against the
worst candidate
in the history of presidential politics
and if i lose it puts more pressure
i wish it was good i wish he was good
i'd have less pressure you know i mean
how do you listen to a guy like
how do you lose to a guy like this
and by the way we're leading in north
carolina paul just
i think we're leading everywhere where
people are intelligent
[Music]
[Applause]
and you actually we just got to report
the lines are through the roof on areas
that would more typically vote for us
i'm trying to be diplomatic when i say
that
thank you
but this election is a matter of
national security it really is we can't
let this happen
it's a matter of national security the
bidens got rich while america got robbed
now big tech you see what's going on
with big tech
is censoring these stories to try and
get biden out of this impossible jab
he's in a big jam you know his son left
his laptop
at some place fixed my laptop he forgot
to pick it up
the guy from the laptop it looks like he
saw it he said wow this is really
criminal stuff
he brought it to the fbi can you believe
it
this could only happen to me
and the people of north carolina though
this could only happen
can you imagine he's fixing a laptop he
says this is really bad stuff i think
i'll bring it into law enforcement
anyway they've got it they've got a lot
of them i hear they have stuff
coming out you won't even believe yeah
you'll believe it he and his family are
crooked
and they were caught they got caught now
they're being protected by big tack
and a big tech persists in coordination
with the mainstream media
we must immediately strip them of their
section 230 protection
okay it's very simple
and we all believe in freedom of the
press but don't forget big tech got
something years ago that let them become
big tech
they got total protection they don't get
sued they don't get anything they're
totally protected
so the government gave that so that
takes away that little feeling that
oh gee we can't talk to them about
freedom of the press etc
no we're going to take away their
section 230 unless they shape up
and believe it or not even the democrats
agree of course the only problem we have
when they say that we're against
it's like the wall you know we're
building the wall it's going up
it took it was so hard it was so hard
getting that done there was
very few people could have gotten that
done we're up over 400 miles but here's
what's happened
i just think back all i had to say is we
will
not build the world it would have given
me so much fun
i had to say we were building it but we
got it going and we have the safest
southern border we've ever had so that's
all
in 2016 north carolina
voted to fire this corrupt and decrepit
political establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
of the united states
who put america first
[Applause]
and we've done a job we've done a great
job and
it's been amazing and i'll come back you
know we nobody's ever done anything like
what we did and then we got hit by the
china plague
should not let it happen and
we're now coming back at a level that
nobody's ever seen before nobody thought
it was possible they thought we'd be at
42
unemployment we just hit 7.8 can you
believe it
now we were 3.5 i even went to north
carolina i needed a good chief of staff
i said
joy where is where's where's mark better
where's mark
where's mark
[Music]
[Applause]
come here mark come here
[Music]
can you imagine i had to go to north
carolina to find my chiefess
ah he's great now he's done a great job
he's done a great job and he followed me
and i said you know what
i just tested positive he didn't care he
was in that helicopter
hey he's from north carolina where can i
he's great doing a great job you elected
me to restore the principle that's
a nation's first duty and it's to
its own citizens we're about our country
right i'm president of our country we're
not president of the world
we're not president of the world usa so
if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician it's because i'm
not a politician
[Music]
and if i don't always seem to be playing
by the rules of the washington
establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you
harder than any other president has ever
fought for our country's people
and right now i'm fighting to eradicate
the virus and we're doing really a good
job we're rounding the turn you see
what's going on in europe it's flaming
up
these characters back there they say
well look at europe well i'll tell you
what go take a look
go take a look now we're doing a great
job we're doing a great job they didn't
give the credit i don't want the credit
but our vice president worked 24 hours a
day
and we had a lot of governors they
worked with us but we had some that were
really good and some that were really
not so good i'll let you know one day
i'll write a little book and i'll tell
you who the good ones were
we made a lot of people look good we've
done a great job and we have some
incredible
statistics but we want to rebuild the
economy and that's happening quickly we
have the greatest economy we've ever had
think of it
now we closed it down we saved 2 million
lives by closing it down
we closed it down and now we're building
it back up and by the way north carolina
tell your governor open up your state
open up your school
right
[Music]
they'll announce on november 4th so
ladies and gentlemen we're opening up
north carolina and by the way
pennsylvania you know we've been suing a
lot of states that are run by democrats
right
i always call them high crime but the
fact is that's where the crime is
but you know we've been suing a lot of
people and we just won in michigan
against what she did was terrible i mean
she did
it's like a prison warden and uh
so michigan we won on constitutional
basis they have to open it up
you got to open this one up i mean the
people want to get back
the kids want to be back in school 99.9
like you heard yesterday announced you
know my baron
my tall baron he's very tall
my beautiful baron enhancer he is
handsome but my beautiful baron had it
he recovered like so fast i said wait a
minute
how long did that take they have the
strongest immune systems they're better
than all of us that's what they are
they're kids for some reason but we've
learned
about this disease you've got to open up
your businesses open up your schools get
it going
we have incredible therapeutics we have
incredible drugs we have in my opinion a
cure because
i took something regeneron it was you
know highly sophisticated stuff
the antibodies and eli lilly makes an
incredible drug
and what we've done is incredible this
has all been over the last six months
it's all happened we got the fda for
fast approvals
they would have taken years and years
and they're doing it they came to me on
one sir this will take approximately
two years i said nope i needed to prove
tomorrow they said that's not good
we got it too we got it
but this is the most important election
in the history of our country
joe biden has made a corrupt bargain in
exchange for his party's nomination
he has handed control of the socialist i
mean he's given control of this party
the democrats they used to be like
normal people now they're
socialists marxists communists
[Music]
that's right you said it i didn't say it
communists
and some people would say far left
lunatics look at the green new deal
[Applause]
well don't slap too hard go out and vote
we'll clap later
because these people are crazy if he
wins the radical left
we'll be running the country because
they're addicted to power
and god help us if they win we won't
have our country anymore and it'll never
be able to come back
they never do you know if you look 20
years ago venezuela had oil had wealth
had
less than 20 years ago had everything
now they don't have water
they don't have food they don't have
medicine
they have nothing but killing all over
their streets
this happened in a short period of time
and it's the same ideology you see it
the democrat party talks about decency
and decorum while they
demonize cancel you know the word cancel
right they want to cancel your culture
and persecute anyone who refuses to bend
to their will i don't think they like me
too much
they don't like me too much
[Music]
thank you
that's really enough that's another you
know why because those words
nobody has ever heard them at a
political event
i like ronald reagan and they'd say we
like your ronald reagan but that's
but nobody's ever heard those words
right we love you whoever
what no seriously what politician has
ever heard those words i've never said
those words
and that happens and i consider that a
great honor and thank you very much
but the democrats smear decent americans
as racist
slander our nation as evil indoctrinate
our children and incite
anti-american riots on our streets that
we could control
in 25 minutes as we did in minneapolis
as we do wherever we go but they have to
invite us in by law they have to invite
us in
we want to go to portland so bad that
one would take 15 minutes to set
15 minutes and the man that shot
another innocent man his was an innocent
man shot
killed instantly killed he said what
happened
well we haven't arrested him two days
three days went by we sent in the u.s
marshals
took 15 minutes it was over 15 minutes
it was over
we got him
they knew who he was they didn't want to
arrest him and 15 minutes that ended
anyway but and they call themselves
peaceful protesters you know in theory
we're not supposed to be and look at all
the masks you know they keep saying
nobody wears bears wear the masks
although then they come out with things
today did you see cdc
that 85 of the people wearing the mask
catch it
okay
can you have my friend eddie's a nice
guy tony tony found you
he's a nice guy he said this is not a
threat this is not a problem don't worry
about this not that what's the problem
it's the craziest thing
and he said do not wear a mask do not
wear a mask under any circumstances
don't wear a mask don't don't don't
right
so we don't wear a man then they say oh
we're a man i never saw do you ever see
any conflicts but he's a nice guy so i
keep him around right we'll keep him all
right
he's a democrat everybody knows that
he's cuomo's friend cuomo did the worst
job of
any governor in the united states
almost 40 000 people died more
at 11 000 at least and you know i gave
him this big convention center
2800 betsy didn't use it i gave him a
ship
i gave him the great hospital ship meant
for wars
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
incredible you have to see the ship i've
been on it many times
it's incredible they didn't use it
instead they sent sick people back into
nursing homes right
to disgrace the democrat party is
ashamed of america the republican party
is proud of america
and that's a big
so you're not being set up tonight right
so i'm doing this town hall with uh
comcast c-o-n right khan
because it's a con job comcast c-o-n not
c-o-m
c-o-n cast so
i'm doing it and it's nbc the worst home
of
sleepy eyes chuck todd and some others
and they gave lester holt he's a beauty
they gave
joe biden a week ago a town hall
and it was meant for children in fact
speaking of barron trump
fully recovered in like a record time
baron trump would do great on that show
because he's a young child
they asked him questions that a child
could answer any child
a smart child not such a smart child
and they got taken apart you know it was
a joke it was a joke
and so they asked me if i'd do it and i
figured what the hell we get a free hour
on television
and we have savannah guthrie she's
always lovely isn't she
but i figure why not what's the
difference in tone
between they what they did to this guy
that can't put two sentences together
and what they do to me but with me it's
me it's a life we know what we're doing
and we just go on and we do it
but they're doing him on they're doing
him on abc and actually i'd like to
watch him because i want to see if he
can make it through the program
and and honestly
they'll be so soft george stephanopoulos
i did him a couple of weeks ago was fine
his questions were unfair they said that
the audience is neutral turned it out
that they only had never trumpers in
there but these are kind of
you know little minor facts well that
happened with the other guy too
it was supposed to be neutral it turned
out that they were all like big
democrats right
big democrats because you know what the
fake
news media is corrupt okay it's corrupt
and we've shown it so many times
so i'll see you later on nbc i look
forward to it we're going to be doing it
from miami
where we're doing very well in florida
too by the way we just got numbers back
it was very well and the senior citizens
are liking us i think more and more
every day every day they see what we're
doing
every single day but we're going to be
doing that from florida so you watch
tonight you know if you want to have a
little entertainment watch
let's just see i just want to see the
tone of the way they treated this
character and the way they treat
us it's not me it's us the way they
treat us
so the candidate whose supporters are
burning
american flags and i say all the time
let's put in some kind of a major major
resolution
you burn an american flag you spend one
year in jail do it
[Music]
see that's where the politicians awake
that's the politicians could do this
that's where they're weak the
politicians and you know i think it lost
five to four in the supreme court now we
have a different supreme court hey by
the way can you imagine
we're going to have number three in one
term
which is a record
you know presidents go an entire you
know presidency
one term two terms without ever having
to pick the supreme court i have three
in
the first term their heads are exploding
these people can't believe it you know
what our friends over here they can't
believe what's happening i'll tell you
but we have three and how good is amy
how good is that
right
[Music]
[Applause]
it's happening
they said uh he should not be able to do
this i said why i'm in my fourth year
he should not be allowed to do it but
then they have a quote from
justice ginberg ginsburg talking about i
guess it was uh
obama right that well wait a minute he's
elected for four years he's not elected
for three years that didn't help them
you know that didn't help their cause
no we got it done it looks like it's
going to be done very soon they have a
one week
period where they sit but they're
getting out of committee
and it's very exciting and i'll tell you
what she's been flawless she hasn't made
a mistake
she's toying with us democrat evil
people
are evil the way they treated
justice kavanaugh was one of the
greatest disgraces i've never seen
anything like it and i've watched a lot
of
unfair things i get treated that way all
the time
okay but i want to tell you i've never
seen anything like it the way they went
after justice kavanaugh
with false accusations and everything
else it's a disgrace
but they're not playing that card here
they're not playing that card
at least so far they're not but we'll be
watching very closely but she's been
spectacular she's getting rave reviews
she's a great intellect her professor
who is a great professor many years said
the single greatest student
that he's ever had that meant something
to me you know it's always nice
as long as you're doing it you might as
well put smart people now they'll say he
discriminates
he discriminates against others not like
to have smart people on the supreme
court
and she's been great but the candidate
whose supporters are tearing down
our statues is not going to
deliver any civility and by the way we
solve every problem
and these are democrat radical left
usually but democrat
areas that are having these high crimes
the republicans are doing fantastically
well remember it
no cash bail they do things that nobody
could even conceive of
and they're out of control but you know
what's going to bring it all together
success
because we were bringing it all together
before the plague came in from china it
never happened they shouldn't have let
it happen they let it happen we're not
forgetting
they'll pay for it but before the plague
came in from china
well biden's not going to make him pay
no he's going to get cash
they pay his son a lot of money what's
he going to do say hey you know you
shouldn't do this
and that's true that's like common sense
look at the money they've taken out of
china
i'll tell you what he really is he's a
corrupt politician just remember it and
i'm going to say it more and more
and and facebook and all can try and
shut us down
but you know what everybody knows it you
don't have a kid who gets thrown out of
the military has he got a job for a long
time
his father becomes a vice president and
now this kid's going into every country
walking away with
millions of dollars from every country
with no talent
no skill no expertise and the press
doesn't want to cover it because they're
corrupt
[Music]
is that true i mean how true is that
and then you look at the way joe biden
lives he lives on a politician's salary
for his whole life 47 years right
and he lives in these beautiful houses
all over the place i haven't seen him
i haven't seen him but he's a politician
and you're not supposed to live
like uh you've made 20 million dollars a
year
so he's corrupt as hell and everyone
knows that joe biden and the democrat
socialists
will kill your job and that's what
they've done they've killed your jobs
dismantle your police departments and
that's what they're doing dissolve your
borders
release criminal aliens raise your taxes
by four times
and how about this how about the
fracking there will be no fracking you
know that's what everybody was against
because it you know the super
radical left primaries right there will
be no fracking here's my
no i said there will be how many times
do i have to say it there will be no
now he gets the nomination the following
day he said
no there will be fracking and i said
okay he's going to get killed by the
media on this they never even asked him
the question
i hope you're watching pennsylvania
because you will lose
1 million fracking jobs almost
immediately
because you know what joe has no control
over that party
that's all aoc and crazy bernie and all
these maniacs
but we were coming together really well
there was going to be i was getting
calls from people that normally i
wouldn't want and they wouldn't want me
and they're saying you know it's amazing
we had the best unemployment numbers
we've ever had
we had 160 million people working think
about it 160 million we would never even
close
we were beating china at a level that
they've never been beaten before i was
charging
tariffs they didn't know what the hell
to do and you know they're always going
to overtake
us in 2019. if you go back 15 20 years
10 years
china was always going to overtake us
2019
well in 2019 we became much much bigger
and we were way overtaking them and they
weren't even close
to overtaking us it was just the
opposite
[Applause]
but we were coming together as a country
because everything was good hispanic
americans
african americans asian americans women
people with diplomas people without
diplomas
people with no high school education
phds from mit
everybody was coming together and then
we had to play
but that's going to bring us together
again because you had your best year in
the history of your state
you had the best year last year the
history of your say
you're gonna have a better year coming
up there's gonna be a better year and
watch your third number
watch your third quarter watch your
third quarter
but the radical democrats will
confiscate your guns
destroy your suburbs
i keep hearing about the suburban women
[Applause]
[Music]
the american dream it is i i let you
have the american dream
i wiped out a regulation that will will
destroy the suburbs you know that you
know about that i wiped it out right
they don't want to have a project built
next to their beautiful house right
so why is it that the fake news keeps
saying that women aren't going to like
trump i think you know what women want
more than anything else they want safety
security and they want to be able to
have their houses and
leave me alone right
[Applause]
the suburban woman
and then early on before i realized it
wasn't politically correct sorry folks
have you been doing this so long
i said the suburban housewife loves
trump and they would
by the way the women they loved it does
anybody mind that term is that a bad
term
you know the only people that mind it
those people wear with the cameras look
at them
look how innocent they look and they're
not innocent
they're not innocent the enemy of the
people i call them the enemy of the
people
but anyway so the suburban women
should love trump now this is the same
thing as this is like a carbon copy of
what happened
last time not nearly as bad remember you
had nine states i was gonna lose all of
them the day before
and they were just wrong a little bit i
won all of them so
i was gonna lose all nine they said this
will be a horrible evening for donald
trump
that wasn't president trump that was
donald trump this evening will be over
very shortly then we win florida
we win north carolina
we win south carolina we win georgie
we ran the coast we just ran it one
after another and
remember it said you had this little
crazy chart on
uh nbc and that's when the people
started crying they worked there
my god what am i going to tell my wife
after two and a half years of saying
he's not going to bank it
and remember it said three percent i had
a three percent chance man
so it's a three percent then we won
utah remember we're supposed to lose
utah we won we only won by 22 points you
know
very accurate but so we want you to so
it goes three percent five percent
eight percent 12
21 now they're saying man that sucker
and that number is getting bad up there
that little number then it started
getting smaller you know because they
did they made the numbers small but the
number was actually getting bigger
21 25 then we won a place called north
carolina
[Applause]
so it went from 25 to 32 percent
right do you remember that evening
wasn't that great everything
started off with ohio remember you
cannot win unless you win the great
state of ohio i heard that for a year
and then we won ohio by eight points
everyone said
nobody wins it by eight by the way we're
doing better there now that we did four
years ago
and the great jim jordan and all those
guys
so we won by eight points so that was
the beginning they said wait a minute
not only did he win he won by a lot
but that was like the little signal is
so what's that
so then it goes to like 25 then 31
35 now we hit the 42.
so now i have a 42 chance of winning and
i'm looking at all these
states that i'm leading in most of them
right we won
32 or 34 states so it goes
34 38 and now they're going oh
what's going on here and remember the
guy right
john king at cnn and he's good with the
board i like it you know he got nice
action but you know wasn't so good that
night he was shaking
and he going well okay well look this is
not looking good
this is uh that good i don't know and
now he's a nervous mess
right now and he's going what's gonna
happen
what's gonna who's there heather
oh hammer bill well bill hammer's a good
guy right
phil hemmer is a good guy oh he said
hammer is better i agree with that
everest
hammer is a good guy but you know what
it's very interesting
so then we go from 42 to 48
54 60 64
then 71. this is in our favor
then 78 then you see all the people
screaming and crying
the most beautiful most beautiful
convention center they had that remember
they had the earth that was shaped like
the united states
and they had the podium on the state of
florida out there hanging out over
and i looked i said you know i said to
our great first lady i said first lady
that is the most beautiful looking thing
i've ever seen the way they had it they
spent a fortune
but they knew something was wrong
because they went to grucci
right and they were on the river at the
convention center and they had a big
display of fourth of july the whatever
the hell it is right
the fireworks and they paid
a lot of money but now they had to pay
seven million
they owed seven million dollars to gucci
and they were all set to do it and then
they decided to cancel
so i then called up grucci i said listen
it's way far away from my location but
i'll give you
a million dollars okay i tried to buy
their fireworks i figured i'd give new
york
have a little fun but i'll never forget
that beautiful and it looks so beautiful
five o'clock
it's beautiful they're all looking like
oh they're gonna have a big evening
and by eight o'clock in the evening you
watch these people remember the woman
the
woman was screaming you know the one i'm
screaming
how about her you think she's a
reasonable person to deal with
and she would scream screaming they're
screaming and it was uh
and they talked about the glass ceiling
right the woman breaking the glass
ceiling
and it didn't work out that way the
glass ceiling broke her but there will
be a woman that breaks the glass ceiling
it just won't be hillary
[Applause]
and you know who else it won't you know
who else it won't be
it won't be kamala
[Applause]
won't be it won't be kamala but we worry
about her i'm very concerned about her
because
as you probably just heard just before i
walked out
two of the people that travel with her
her chief of staff and somebody else
in the plane with her all the time uh
they have been tested positive for covet
19.
so we we extend our best wishes right
right
yes we extend our best wishes
we extend our best which is more than
they did to me but that's okay
that's okay so uh let's see what what
happens i mean it's a tricky thing
it's uh it's dust it's a little tricky
thing
masks no mass everything you can do all
you want but you know
you still need help from the boss
we need help from the boss what happened
we need help
yeah we need help it's all right to say
now they'll criticize me for that how
dare he say that
how dare he say that no i'll say it i'll
say it
i'll say it somebody said to me the
other day you're the most famous person
in the world by far i said no i'm not
no i'm not they said yes you are said no
they said who's more famous i said jesus
christ
[Applause]
i'm not taking any chances i'm not going
to have a god
hey i'm not having any arguments
jesus christ i'm not going to take any
chances south
give it i guarantee and let me look up
and i'll say and it's not even close
to defend our constitution i proudly
nominated
amy coney barrett
[Music]
to the united states supreme court it's
been so popular a lot of people
said i got elected because of the united
states supreme court
i don't know that it's true but when i
ran
you know people knew who i was and all
but they didn't know too much about my
politics and they figured maybe i'm
liberal
maybe who knows they didn't know and
they weren't happy because they didn't
know who i was going to appoint as a
supreme court justice you know was i
going to put
a radical left person like he will put
he's got to give a list by the way not
only does he
can he not pack the court which would be
horrible horrible for a country
for that institution but he's got to get
give a list of
10 12 15 20 25 that he will
only pick from because people have to be
able to see
who he's going to pick you can't let
somebody go up and put
a crazy radical left
justice in the supreme court so i'm
going a step further than that they
don't press
them much how about a guy how about if i
said what he said
he said no no i'm not going to say no
i'll tell them after the election oh
that's great that's wonderful
and then these guys walk away no no he's
got to say
about packing the court but he's also
got to say
who from what group will he pick give
the names
because you have to know that you have
to know that
and you know they say that's what won me
the election i don't know if it's true
but a lot of people say because i i came
up and i was having a lot of
when i first went at a lot of fight back
where people were saying well wait a
minute who's he going to pick as a
service
and i said to my people who are some
really great people i said give me
the top 25 who's 20 and then ultimately
expand it to 25
judges lawyers you know a group of
people
give me the top 25 judges etc
in the united states i want the smartest
the best the most brilliant
and i'm going to put them in a list and
i didn't know i don't think almost any
of them
but these are the most respected people
they believe in a thing called
the constitution okay
which binders people won't believe in
he'll be you'll see some real beauties
if they put in the truth right that's
why they don't want to do that
because you couldn't win an election if
you had to do that so i said give me the
top 25
and then i went out and i played a
little bit cute and i said all right i
will pick
somebody liked these people and you know
what that didn't play
they said no you have to pick one of
these people two of these people that's
what i did i said all right i'll do that
and they say that was 20 or 25
points in terms of the percentages of
what i got was a big thing on the united
states supreme court
well i've done it again i've now taken
my original list
and we had two great people put as you
know
justice kavanaugh justice gorsuch
and by the way nobody's ever suffered
like justice kavanaugh what he went
through
nobody but we put justice kavanaugh
justice gorsuch
gorsuch he's they're fantastic
intellects fantastic people
and now we have amy to go along with it
and it's going to be
unbelievable another week they'll be
voting the full senate will be voting
and i don't know what can stop it
because it's uh
she's so good it's a it's a freight
train okay but the fact is
so we'll have three but you know what
joe biden has to say who
if he has because the next the next
president whoever it may be better yes
because if it's not if it's not honestly
you will not have the same
country because the next president the
next term
will have anywhere from one two
three and even four picks a very unusual
i was very unusual three it's a record
but you know what
for a term but you know what the next
could have just by
statistically one two three or four so
your whole court is
as good as we're doing now and if i
didn't do this you wouldn't even have a
second amendment
you wouldn't have a second amendment but
if they put on
two three or four that means they will
override and that's good for 30 40 50
years and you know the judges they go in
young and they last for a long time
which is nice so biden has to go out
and he has to not only talk about not
packing the court because anybody wants
to pack the court shouldn't
shouldn't win and just justice
ginsburg said that she said no the nine
we're friendly we get together we're not
we're for the country she said she made
the greatest case for nine
once you get a big group of people then
you're into the senate you're into the
house you know we've already got that
right
and this is a great institution maybe
our greatest institution and we can't
let some
radical group of people destroy it so
number one he can't back the court and
number two
he's got to explain one of 25 or 30 or
40 or 50 people
but he's got to put up a list of people
from which he'll choose
and the voters have to know who those
people are and he can't get away with
i'll tell you after the election and
then destroy our country he can't do it
so that's it that's it
[Applause]
that's much more interesting than going
off a teleprompter when you think of
that but
no but you got to say it you got to say
it like it is so biden's agenda would be
a
catastrophe for north carolina seniors
and you know that better than anybody
for years
biden tried to cut social security and
medicare people don't know that about
him
but he tried to cut your social security
you know great genius he's going to cut
your social security and your medicare
now biden's pledging
mass amnesty and free health care for
illegal aliens and you saw that
you saw that three months ago when he's
on stage and he said
to all of these very radical left
candidates
who wants to give illegal aliens
free health care and they all raised
their hand and biden didn't
and then you could see his right
shoulder it was
the corpse i say he's the corpse and his
shoulder was
he looked around he didn't know what the
hell was happening
but he knew everyone else's hand was up
remember that though he was like
he knew what was wrong look he's been
there for 47 years hasn't done a damn
thing
he's been there 46 he knew it was wrong
but his right shoulder started moving
and i said i just won the election i
said isn't that nice
and you know what we all have a heart
but what that does is it brings millions
of people into our country they all want
to get health care they want to get
education they want to get all the
things that they want to give them and
you can't do it you can't afford it
but that's what they want so we're not
going to let that happen because it'll
decimate medicare and destroy your
social security and everything else
well i'm president no one will touch
your medicare or your social security
and under my leadership we're developing
the vaccines and therapies and all of
those things and
you vote for me prosperity is happening
already it's happening it's happening so
fast nobody can believe it
we're the number one country in the
world by far for economic comeback
and we went down less than any other
country think of that
normal life that's what we want we want
normal i don't want to talk if we want
normal we want to get back to where we
were
nine months ago eight months ago we want
to have those football stadiums those
great teams of yours we want to have
people sitting next to each other
screaming like crazy you look at the
stands we have a person and then 20
empty seats
no that's not it and we'll be back we're
going to be back very soon next year
will be maybe the greatest economic year
one of the greatest economic years but
maybe
the greatest economic year i think
better than last year last year was your
best i think we're going to do better
[Music]
and to a large extent this election is
about many things but it's between
a trump recovery and abiding depression
because if they get in
they're going to raise your taxes
quadruple
he says it they're going to allow
millions of illegal aliens in
and they're going to let regulations all
of the cutting that i've done on
regulation which is
a number that no president has ever even
come close to whether they were
four eight or in one case more than that
they're going to let all those
regulations come back in and the farmers
know what i'm talking about and the
tobacco growers know what i'm talking
about
because you couldn't even farm your land
you had so many regulations
joe biden would terminate our recovery
delay the vaccine prolong the pandemic
and annihilate north carolina's economy
with draconian
unscientific lockdowns he'll keep you
locked down except at a level that
you've never seen before
you won't have a state by the time this
guy finishes up
biden's plan will crush america my plan
is already crushing the virus look at
our numbers
look at our numbers this week oh
damn it he must have lost his job he
must have been a nice guy
i'm sure he lost his job this week
even the failing new york times the poor
writer
i read this and i said this guy is gone
but i didn't know him so what the heck
the new york times said that we had
so good this is the quote experts are
saying quote
with genuine confidence that the
pandemic in the united states
will be over far sooner than anybody
ever
expected how about that new york times
that's right the writer of that article
is gone now but may he rest in peace
they don't want to say that they're not
happy to hear that because they don't
really have our interests at heart
our early and aggressive actions saved
so many lives millions of lives we
pioneered
all of these incredible therapies and
reduced
the fatality rate 80 think of it 85
we understand the disease and we have
things that work
and i'm working to make the antibody
treatment that i received available to
anybody that wants it that has a problem
free
and it's free because it wasn't your
fault
[Applause]
it wasn't your fault and i only hope it
works as well on you but i tell you i
felt like superman a day later here i am
here i am
i actually looked at the doctor he's
here with us now
great doctors we had so many doctors i
never saw so many doctors
all geniuses lowest iq 187.
and they weren't thrilled but i looked
at them they said i don't know what the
hell you gave me but i want some more of
it
now it was a transfusion and it was like
amazing so we're going to make that
available to everybody we're trying to
get it immediately approved
by the fda and dr han is working at the
fda
and hopefully you don't need it and for
the most part you won't need it i think
for the most part but you need it we're
going to get it to you and you're going
to get it and you're going to get better
and i call it a cure they call it a
therapeutic i call it a regeneron
and they have others that are very
similar great companies i told you
before eli lilly etcetera
through operation warp speed we will
have 100 million vaccine doses before
the end of this year
the vaccine will end the pandemic but
it's ending anyway i mean they go crazy
when i say it it's going to peter out
and it's going to end but we're going to
help the end and we're going to make it
a lot faster with the vaccine and with
the therapeutics and frankly with the
cures
so we're joined today by some incredible
warriors and
friends of ours congressman david rouser
where is he david
david rouser he's a warrior
how we doing david we're doing okay in
the state you're doing good
you have any competition in the race any
competition or
not much i love that i like when they
say not much sir
but if they have i i'm always there to
help right
i'm there to help thank you david great
job
we have a candidate for north carolina
superintendent of public instruction
catherine truitt catherine
great great thank you
good job catherine i heard that
chairwoman of the republican national
committee
ronna mcdaniel ronnie
who just recovered herself by the way
for anybody that's sitting look they're
all jumping oh she just recovered let's
get the hell out of here
now ron is great where is ron right here
thank you ron she's great she did a
great job she ran michigan for us four
years ago she did so well
and many many decades since a republican
won michigan we won michigan i said i
want that person
the rnc i want that person running the
rnc she's great so rana thank you very
much
she just fully recovered from
coven a lot of people are recovering you
know people are recovering 99
99 plus plus and now with what you can
do you know one thing i do say get there
early get to the hospital early
get there early they can do things lots
of things but don't get there like get
there early
and north carolina gop chairman a friend
of ours a great
gentleman michael watley thank you
michael
great job how are we doing doing all
right
looking like a good win right and are
the numbers that big standing online
getting ready to vote right bigger than
you anticipated
now he's saying the right things
thank you man not here it was on the it
was broadcast today the numbers are
crazy
you know what it's called and this is
what we're going to have we're going to
have a red
wave
right they don't want to send in the
ballots and have the ballots thrown away
into a dumpster
who are you for trump get rid of that
one get ready this is the craziest thing
they want to vote our people want to go
they want to vote it's going to be a big
beautiful red wave and let them put in
their
deal and we'll check in every one of
them we're watching very closely where
they came from
where they went how did they get there
right all this stuff that's going on
not a day goes by when you don't read
about what crooked things are happening
but the red wave will crush it and those
are people that are going to get there
on
november 3rd and previous to that you
know the
open voting when you can vote but
they're going to get there and people
are talking about it already and you're
seeing that aren't you huh
you're saying that that's great michael
that's great gonna be a
lot of fun because it was a landslide
well we're gonna see
we're gonna see but we got a good shot
no we're doing great in pennsylvania
we're doing great in michigan doing
great in arizona
i heard some very good numbers just now
in nevada
um we're doing good i mean we're doing
good all over the place and i don't want
to say it too loud because you know they
get all this money they'll spend money
like crazy
but you know ultimately money doesn't
get you there because i spent
25 of what crooked hillary spent right
i spent 25 and even after i won they
said he didn't do as good a job at
fundraising i said i spent less money
and i got criticized that we want
you know my father taught me a long time
ago if you can win for less money that's
a good thing not a bad thing
right michael under my administration we
built the greatest economy in the
history of the world
and now we are doing it again in my
first three years
family income increased by six
thousand dollars more than five times
the gains
in all eight years under the last
administration
think of that so we did
more than really more than eight times
african-american income grew nine times
more than it did
under biden and obama nine times
african american unemployment hispanic
american unemployment asian american
unemployment all reached in history
record highs highest in history we're
getting them all back they're all coming
back
we lifted 6.6 million americans out of
poverty
since the china virus we've created a
record
11.4 million american jobs we have never
produced
jobs at that level in that speed
we've already cut the unemployment rate
in half
and think of it seven point eight seven
point nine that sounds terrible but you
know it sounds pretty good when they're
telling you about the 42
right because i think at 42 you know
what are you going to do we have this
crazy situation that happened
and uh eight 7.8 it's pretty incredible
when you think about it
and we'll get that way down and it's
going down fast under right
well yeah just watch this under biden
it took 30 months to recover more than
half of the jobs lost in
their crisis it wasn't a crisis though
it was not great times but it wasn't a
crisis
we did it in five months so they had 30
months and they had the weakest
recovery in the history of our country
dating back
actually to when they started 1929 it
was the weakest
recovery in the history of our country
and then he wants to tell us how to do
things
for 47 years he did nothing i love these
guys you know for 47 years he did
nothing
now all of a sudden he wants to do all
these things that i did already
i could do better you shouldn't have let
china and well for two months he was
saying
i was xenophobic because i closed the
borders very early didn't i
jobs have been recovering 23 times
faster than the obama biden
recovery 23 times not 23
23 times
and these numbers come from the great
larry kudlow who's a good man by the way
we've spent the last four years
reversing the damage
joe biden inflicted over us for 47
years think of it biden has waged a
decades-long assault on your state
against your state's tobacco growers he
was a cheerleader for nafta which was a
disaster
tpp which would have been a disaster had
i not terminated it
would have destroyed your state it would
have destroyed manufacturing
in our country and he was totally in
favor
of china's entry into the world trade
organization that's when they took off
like a rocket
but not so good anymore for half a
century biden twisted his blade into the
heart of north carolina workers
he should not be asking for your votes
he should be begging for your
forgiveness
that's what he should be doing what a
job he did
i mean you go back four or five years
you people were hurting
you were hurting i have plenty of
friends in this state you were hurting
for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding
foreign nations fighting foreign wars
and defending foreign borders
countries you never heard of but now
we're
finally protecting our nation rebuilding
our cities
and we are bringing our jobs our
factories
and our troops back home to the usa
it's probably the main reason i ran in
the first place
and i made the statement the other day
it sort of made sense to me
if obama and biden did a good job
i would have never run i mean thank you
i only did it
i only ran because they did a horrible
job and there was no unity you had
ferguson look at what happened in st
louis look at what happened in baltimore
look what happened in oakland
look at what happened there was hatred
all over the place now they say oh
wasn't that beautiful
what they did was they did a terrible
job that's why i'm your president
because if they did a good job i
wouldn't have run
i had a very nice life believe me i had
a very like
and by the way how many of these rallies
have you stand up please
north carolina how many what number is
it don't be a baron
6-0 60.
[Applause]
they have a group of 12 women and i see
them a lot
and i say north carolina they remind me
of that no matter where we go and
so 60 that's a lot but that's only about
20 so you have a long way to
i'm sure their husbands are thrilled
where are you going i'm going to
well at least here you're close right
and you might and you don't mind right
we like him
we like him great women thank you very
much that's really nice
wow that's really nice to save our auto
industry i withdrew from the
last administration's trans-pacific
partnership
i ended the nafta nightmare and signed
the brand new usmca which is just now
kicking in and has turned out to be
incredible for our farmers our
manufacturers
everyone said it couldn't be done
there's no way you could end nafta i
ended it it was one of the worst
trade deals ever made i took the
toughest ever action to confront china's
rampant theft of american jobs
we've achieved energy independence and
we've done it while protecting our
pristine environment you know we have
the best environmental numbers we've
ever had meaning i guess over 50 years
because before that
you didn't have too much action right
but we have the best
environmental numbers ozone numbers so
many other numbers
in the meantime china russia
india all these countries they're
spewing stuff into the air i keep
telling my people
i say you know i love clean air but
russia and china you look at a map you
have all these spots and
india and many others are spewing it in
what do you suggest well we don't think
you should sell straws anymore oh great
okay that's good
let me hit that the straw right and i
say okay the straw is good that's a
little straw that's
okay let's what about the plastic plate
what about the carton what about the
glass that's out of plastic
well we'll get to that later these
people are crazy
i recently signed an order placing a
moratorium
on offshore drilling off the coast of
florida georgia
south carolina and north carolina so
you'd have to worry about any oil spills
in your beautiful land
[Applause]
you don't have to worry look how happy
she is she obviously lives on the water
you don't have to worry about those
spills at the same time i have made it
so great for energy
you know we've never had energy like we
do we're number one in the world now by
far
and totally energy independent in 2017 i
proudly signed a historic executive
order making it official
governing policy to buy american
and hire americans
i saw biden the other day he's standing
here
like this
nobody's got a sign hire american i said
i've been saying that for 15 years
it's amazing and you know this one when
the tennessee valley authority
replaced part of its american workforce
with foreign workers
i told the board chairman chairman you
fired out
your fire chairman you know what he was
making
this had nothing to do with me he was
making eight million dollars a year he's
the highest paid
government official semi-government it's
like a private semi-private deal
eight million dollars a year and i said
you're fired
and what happened is uh as soon as i
said that they hired all the employees
back from tennessee and five other
states six other states
mississippi they're all back
and they were great they were great so
we do our little things right
we did that one and it was great my
opponent's immigration plan
is the most extreme in the history of
our country
biden's plan would eliminate u.s borders
by implementing nationwide catch and
release that's catch
a murderer comes over you catch them
what do you do
well not much most of them don't say
they kill people right
you catch them you take their name and
you release them into our country
it was a big deal it sounds easy i ended
it but you want to see
tough go through courts goes through but
i ended it i ended catch and release
one of the worst things now we release
them
you know when we release them release
them back into their country
we don't release them in our country
anymore we say congratulations we've got
them
look at all those people standing up out
there wow sorry
sorry we didn't get your seats
well they're strong they're strong
people they're from north carolina
making every community into a sanctuary
city this is their goal and suspending
all
removals of any illegal alien no matter
how bad they are
murderers rapists they have a deal with
bernie sanders crazy bernie
he lost twice greatest loser of all time
he lost the first time
and he took it that he lost the second
time elizabeth warren should have
dropped out i'd be running against him
that would be okay i don't care
there'd be more energy smaller base more
energy
but it happened twice to bernie
but i would really be watching and very
careful
because it would be the total
nullification of u.s borders they don't
want borders they want to have this
country and what would happen would be
our country would be
overwhelmed with illegal immigration
coming
in your jobs crime would go through the
roof
and now as i said we have the strongest
southern border in the history of our
country over 400 miles of war
wall will be completed very soon ms-13
and criminal cartels would have rampaged
freely all over the country if it wasn't
for ice and border patrol
so we've gotten rid of thousands of
ms-13
we delivered them back out of our
country we said congratulations here
they are you take them we're not taking
them
these are bad some bad people if biden
wins
your borders are gone which means your
health care is gone the middle class is
gone
and your safety is gone it's very simple
biden has
pledged with bernie sanders this they
made this agreement you know what it is
they all agreed
to a thing we call it the manifesto
my idea it's called the manifesto he's
pledged to eliminate our requirement
that newcomers to our society be
financially self-reliant
we want them to be able to make a pledge
that they're not going to take from us
and he'll provide unlimited welfare he
wants to
for anybody anywhere in the world that
comes into our country
i said that's a great idea where we're
going to get the money sleepy joe
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure border in u.s
history and we're finishing the wall so
we're up to now 407
i think 406 407 we're doing 10 miles a
week
nobody believes we invested 2.5 trillion
dollars in the u.s military
defense spending in north carolina has
soared
to more than one billion dollars a year
many times what it was
[Applause]
and by the way all made in the usa we
have uh
the greatest machinery
ever made by any nation in history
russia
china every one of them they're all
jealous what we have is
uh not even to be talked about i
actually mentioned this at a rally about
two months ago
and they said he's giving away
information no i'm not i'm telling you
something
we got stuff that they dream about all
made in the usa one
2.5 trillion dollars and you know what
hope to god we've
redone our nuclear we're number one in
the world by far
it was going down the tubes it was old
and tired
but hope to god we never have to use it
remember when i came in they said with
his personality we'll have we'll be in a
war in the first week
where's where's the war right where's
the war
remember you would have been on a war
without me because north korea were
going to have a nice nuclear war with
north korea and now i get along great
with him and everyone says oh that's
terrible that i get along no it's a good
thing
you know getting along is a good thing
not a bad thing and you get along
through strength
not through a weakness you never get
along through a week
and we launched the first new branch
of the united states armed forces and i
never even talked when i came to north
carolina and talked to you i never said
this
so we actually did more than i promised
i'm the only politician if you call me
that
i'm the only politician that actually
did more than i promised because i never
talked about
the space force i never talked about
right
and as i you know sat for a year and i
watched and i saw what was going on with
russia and with china and with others i
said wait a minute
we're going to fall way behind we can't
do that and we launched the
space force and jim imhoff and some of
the people in the senate were
fantastic and the house and we got it
passed so we have first time it's 75
years think of that
a new force and it's a big force and
it's an important one
we passed va choice for our veterans and
va accountability
nobody thought that could happen 42
years
and we took over 100 of the isis
caliphate
when i came in it was a mess they were
all over the place
we took over 100 and we killed the
leader of
isis and founder of isis al-baghdadi
they were after him for
15 years and we took out the world's
number one terrorist
the mass murderer of many american
troops and many other troops and many
other people
kasim solomani is dead
and i withdrew from last administrations
disastrous
150 billion plus 1.8 billion in cash can
you believe it
five plane loads of cash figure that one
the iran nuclear deal a disaster and uh
you know the first call i'm going to get
after we win it's going to be from
iran can we make a deal because their
country's going to hell with the
sanctions and all of the things we've
done
and they want to make a deal i said why
don't you wait till after the election i
said but if you wait till after the
election this is going to be much
tougher
but i said wait till after the election
because you you can't make a deal now
you got to see a sleepy joe because if
sleepy joe gets in you make the greatest
deal ever made
and china will own us remember what i
said i kept my promise
recognized the true capital of israel
and opened the american
embassy in jerusalem
got it bill
and we got it built mr congressman we
got it well too
they wanted two billion dollars to build
it i said maybe we could do cheaper i
said
to my people i said you know this story
find something maybe we own some land we
did it had a building on it
so we were going to spend 2 billion i
said well let's renovate the existing
building is it big enough oh it's too
big actually
and how's the location much better than
the one we were going to buy in
jerusalem
i said i come back with a price david
friedman who's one of the most
successful lawyers now he's the
ambassador to
israel so he calls me up two days later
he says sir i think we can do it for 350
000 i said david
so from 2 billion i said well what's the
difference between the 2 billion version
and the 1
350 000 he said sir honestly the 350
will have a better location a better
building it's actually better
now who would believe soros like this
and i actually told him i did something
i don't think congressman i've ever done
in my life i said david it's too cheap
it doesn't sound good make it more
expensive please
so we made it 500 000 not bad right and
we opened it up a few
months later so not only did we name
jerusalem became the capital of israel
we got the building built
this thing would have taken 10 years 20
years
would it cost 5 billion it would have
been ridiculous
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights have been
fighting over that
for 52 years
and a set of endless wars were forging
peace in the middle east
i did more in 47 months than sleepy joe
biden did in 47 years that's true
and now he's pushing the most far-left
agenda ever put forward
by a presidential nominee the biden plan
would destroy your social security
and he would destroy all pre-existing
conditions and you know it and so does
he biden's running mate
sponsored a bill to outlaw private
health insurance we have 180 million
people
that love their private health care
biden vowed to terminate our travel bans
on
jihadist regions and surge refugee
admissions he's agreed to this with
crazy bernie
by 700 think of that does that sound
reasonable
opening the floodgates to radical
islamic terrorism i said no thank you
he wants to ban school choice and
charter schools
and in the second term and i've already
started
we will provide school choice to every
parent in america one of the most
important
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities
great jobs and limitless future a
limitless future for all americans
and just in concluding first of all it's
great to be with you on this gorgeous
day this is beautiful
it's been a great state i mean
my granddaughter you know what happened
right
you know the name of my granddaughter
carolina
carolina
am i allowed to say that to south
carolina because i love them too can i
maybe do it
am i okay with that can i have you
no it's carolina beautiful over the next
four years we'll make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we'll end our reliance on china
we've already started we're well on our
way
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assault and law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
we will strike down terrorists who
threaten our citizens
and we will keep america out of endless
ridiculous foolish stupid
foreign wars
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength that's what we have
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency already signed hits
in and
january 1st don't give biden the credit
for it please
he won't even know what it is he'll say
what did i do
and further reduce the cost of
prescription drugs at levels that you've
never seen before
we will strongly protect medicare and
social security
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states
will be the first nation to land an
astronaut
on mars and it'll be soon and nasa is
now
the number one space center in the world
by far
and it was up it was virtually abandoned
when i took over
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and restore patriotic education
to our schools
[Applause]
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag
[Applause]
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national model
in god we trust and that won't be
changed
they took the word god out of the pledge
of allegiance
and they got absolutely decimated they
put it back they said no no we didn't
mean and then they took it out a couple
of other times
that's the way they're going but it's
not going to happen not even going to
come close for years
you had a president who apologized for
america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
north carolina
so again this is the most important
election
of our lives maybe in the history of our
country
so get your friends get your family
get your neighbors get out and
vote the red wave is coming the red
wave is coming
and remember early voting starts guess
when today so
go down there from wilmington to
winston-salem
from asheville to charlotte from
greensboro
to right here in greenville
we inherit the legacy of north carolina
patriots who gave their blood
sweat and tears for this beloved nation
we
love our nation
we stand on the shoulders of american
heroes who cross the oceans
blaze the trails settle the continent
tamed the wilderness dug out the panama
canal
laid down the railroads raised up the
skyscrapers
won two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and made america the single greatest
nation
in the history of the world and you
haven't
seen anything yet
[Applause]
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country
we are returning power to you the
american people
and we are returning it fast faster than
anyone ever
thought possible
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning
[Music]
we are one movement one people
one family and one glorious nation under
god
and together with the incredible people
of north carolina
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again we're
proud
[Applause]
we will make america
safe again quickly
and we will make america great again
thank you everybody go out and vote
[Music]
oh
there's no need to feel down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
boys
[Music]
i was watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ymca they can't stop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
why
[Music]
blue
[Music]
just a small town girl
living in a lonely world
[Music]
playing
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] you
it goes on and on and on
[Music]
ah
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
just one more time
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so uh
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
much more than this
[Music]
to mention
[Music]
i find each charge of course
each cap will step
on the volley way
more much more than this
i had
yes
i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so amusing
to think i did all that
and may i say
not in a
oh
[Music]
the things
i am
[Music]
um
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
uh
me
[Music]
uh
hey
[Music]
just hit me with the tree
[Music]
me
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
me crazy
i don't wanna be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
thank you i know you guys give a bad rap
thank you
all right guys let's get it right now
let's get it right
let's get it right hey losers
okay i'm not sure
foreign
it was bad
you